Sothere'snowamovement,anefforttoputthebindementiastorylinethebitedeclinestoryline
andIwannabereallycarefulhere,'causeeverybodywantsahottakeonthis,andthetruthisthehot
takesarefallingflatguystopeopleontheleftandontheright,withthehottakesonthisissue.If
you'relookingforsomekindofblackandwhitehottakeonthisturnthisoffrightnow,I'llgiveyou
asecondbecauseyou'renotgonnagetthatformeifyou'reexpectingmetosayforexample,Joe
biteinisobviouslysufferingfromadvanceddementia.Couldn'tbepresidentandthisaloneisthe
reasonnottovoteforhim,overTrump.Ifbinisindeedthenomineeyou'renotgonnafindthathere
ontheotherhand,ifyou'reexpectingmetosaytheentire...JoeBidendementiastoryisa
coordinatedeffortinvolvingrepublicans,TrumpandRussiansyouarenotgoingtofindthathereas
well.
Thisiswhat'sgoingon.
I'vebeencoveringJoeBidenconcerningcognitiveincidenceforalongtime,now,justlikeI've
beencoveringDonaldTrumpsJoeBidenisa77­year­oldmanwhohasclearlysloweddownover
thelastfouryears.Writingitallofftohisstutteriswrong,gobackandlookathisdebatefrom
2012,withPaulRIandlookatallsortsofotherstuff.Youwillseethatwhatisgoingonrightnow
isnotJoeBiden.stutter.IfindthisconcerningandIfinditlessconcerningthanthecognitive
declinethatwehaveapparentlyseenfromDonaldTrump.
Andifyougivemetheoptionoftwoguyswithpossiblecognitivedecline,"bianandTrumpI
pickedbyanover­Trumpeverysingletimeeveninthemidstofcognitivedecline.Binwouldbe
betterthanTrump"bianVPwouldbebetterthanpensBinwouldpickbetterSupremeCourtjudges
period,okay,sothere'snoquestionaboutit.
03/10/20 Page12of17
davidpakmanshow­2020­03­09­commercialfree
Now,thereisnoquestionthatinadditiontothecognitivedecline,questionsbeingrealand
legitimatethereisalsonodoubtthatbothRepublicansandBerniesupportershavescaleduptheir
socialmediacampaignabout"biancognitivedecline.
ThereareBerniesupporters,sharingTrumpvideosofJoeBidencognitivedecline,thereareTrump
supporters,sharingvideosmadebyBerniesupporters,purportingtoshowJoe"biancognitive
decline.
TheBerniesupportersaresharingthe"bianvideosbecausetheythinkit'llhelpBerniebabyand
becomethenominee.Iseethatasincrediblyunlikely.Lookatthepolls,MichiganhasBidenup24
and21,that'stheonestateBernie'scountingontomorrow.Ithinkthatthey'resimply
mathematicallywrong,butIunderstandwhytheBerniesupportersaredoingit.
TheTrumpsupportersaresharingtheBIanddementias,fortworeasons:Numberone,theywanna
justsochaoswithintheDemocraticprimary,theyseebinasgainingtheywantto.Nowit'sso
doubt.Maybehelpburnyoulittle.Gettothinkthelastaslongaspossible.Andnumbertwo,Trump
supportersaresharingthe"biandementiavideosbecausetheywannabeabletosay,youguyshave
beensaying,Trump'scognitivecognitively,declining.Soisbidandlookatthesevideos.SoI'mnot
goingtofallintoanyblackandwhitenonsenseonthis,andweareactuallyunlikelytodoaswellin
termsofviewershipoverthenextcoupleofweeksbecauseI'mnotgonnadotheBlack­White
nonsensethateverybody'sjumpinginononewayortheotheryouallknowI'vebeencoveringby
andforaverylongtime,we'vebeencoveringhispoliticalviewswe'vebeencoveringhispossible
cognitivedecline.I'mnotgoingtostartsharingnonsense.AndDonaldTrumpretweetedadoctored
videoof"bianwhichnowhasbeenflaggedasmanipulatedbyTwitterandotherplatforms.The
videotweetedbyTrumpSocialMediaDirector,Dan"SavinoandretweetedbyTrumppurportsto
beanotheroneofthesebiandcognitiveincidentsweare,itseemslikebinissaying,Wecanonly
re­electDonaldTrumpinreality.Thevideoiscutmid­sentence,andit'scompletelydeceptive.
Here'sthevideoasit'sbeenpresentedtothetradersonacampaignthat'saboutmegatonintoone
aboutWhatwerefor...Becausewecannotgetreallyelectitcannotwinthisre­election.Eseme,we
couldonlyrealletdancing.
Sothismakesitsoundlikebinissaying,Wecanonlyre­electDonaldTrumptheactualvideohas
bidandsayingIfweengageinacircularfiringsquadontheleftwewillcertainlybere­electing
DonaldTrump.Here'sthefullcliponeorawillpredicatetogether.Werunonthepreparedofthe
potter.Youcan'tfind...AndIturn...Churchesisprimaryforacampaignthat'saboutaouttake,to
oneaboutoverfor...Becausewecan'tnotgetelected.
Itcannotwinhisre­electiontiecanonlyweletgofromit,ifinfactwecanengageinthiscircuit,
onetoit'sgottobeapositivecanvassingus,sadly,thisisoneofthebiteandattackvideosthatwas
putoutbyTrumpandhisteam,butitwaswidelysharedbyBerniesupporters.Andit'sjustabad
lookguys,it'sareallybadlook.ThisislikeifIsayinavideo,theJewsaretheenemyofthepeople'
whitesupremacistshavesaidforyearsandsomeonecutsitandsayswhat?DidyouseewhatDavid
backandsaid?
AndtheyshowonlymesayingtheJewsaretheenemyofthepeople.That'sessentiallywhatthisis.
03/10/20 Page13of17
davidpakmanshow­2020­03­09­commercialfree
Doesn'tmatterwhatsideyou'reon,Igetit,Igetwhat'sgoingonintheDemocraticprimaryanda
lotofpeopleareactingoutofdesperationatthispointandIunderstandthedesperationbelieveme,
weshouldandcanhavethebid,andcognitivedeclinediscussion,butnoticethathalfthepeople
havingthatdiscussionneversaidawordaboutTrump'scognitivedeclinearen'tsayingawordabout
burninghavingaheartattackatage77.ifyou'regoingtotalkaboutthisstuff,talkaboutallofit,or
otherwisetobethere'sgonnaberealquestionsraisedaboutthemotivesofsomeofthepeople
participatinginthis.AndagainIsharetheconcernIsharetheconcernI'maprogressiveBIinis...
Well,tomyright,Iunderstandit,butcomeonguys,let'sgetittogether.